[تصفيق]
آرون إيزابيل كانت كذلك أخيرًا
فتاة بلجيكية جميلة في باردا تشارلي نيللي
غرفة معادلة الضغط القاتلة صباح جيلوت ريدها لا
سينتيلا بوابا فرعون داتو مايوت شرقًا
اتضح أن هناك بعضنا البعض نصنع نقاط قوتنا
لكراهية الدولة نعم من سارلهم
أرض كامارا جميع الأنواع هو الصورة
غاب عن المسلسل تماما نعم نحن
رأيته لمدة شهر لذلك نحن سعداء
لتلقي اللعبة نفتقد
التواصل مع الناس أو حتى السلطة
لتبادل القدرة على تقديم المشورة حتى يتسنى لنا
تلبيس الناتي سيحتفل في الصباح
الطريق الجغرافي أو الأيسر ولكن كلارا
كلارا ديدلويس خراب ميشيل روبيدو
تم تصوير الأخلاق في السلطعون الذي بدأ فيه
العيب نقوله عجل ونفعله
صباح لدي رئيس سلسلة ولكن وفقا ل
جميع سواغات سقف
المحل مجهز بالكاميرات
العد الذي تراه على السقف
الوصول إلى الأشخاص الذين يدخلون هذا
أنهم باردو قد أدرجوا النار الناعمة
mineira datati لا تفعل شيئًا في وضع joël
Farré خصومات الولاء و
كان رد فعل ولكن الخيول لاحظت لي مين